[Music]
Matt are you at this point a party in
hardcore alcohol drugs rock and roll or
no your skin under control I thought you
it's not me okay my father's an
alcoholic I don't drink I don't smoke at
all ever so you're not doing intro you
you have control right now John because
you're not have a control issue I mean
no I've got some I got listen I got
major problem I'm a narcissist
anti-social I mean how got some issues
are you Jule is your July 2nd year was
your birthday yeah July says your
license your birthday yeah narcissus and
would you would you consider yourself
pathological liar as well or no no you
wouldn't put yourself there no
absolutely not who to be able to face
some of these guys and stayed that yeah
no natural like there's a there's a fine
line there's books written about
sociopaths that they can just look at
you and tell you would you say so you're
somewhat there or no well a saying about
sociopaths what I'm saying is I'm not a
pathological liar pathological liars
tend to Tyndale they feel good about
lying date they lie it's impulsive they
almost can't control it some of them
there are different versions of
pathological I wrote a whole book on a
guy named Marcus shrinker who's a
pathological liar and so I've read I've
read multiple books on the subject and
studies and he's clearly a pathological
liar what's the difference in your eyes
pathological liar sociopath what's the
difference well most almost pathological
liars are always pretty much always
sociopaths so you could be a sociopath
and not be a pathological liar how's
that well a sociopath is just somebody
who has it they are not basically you're
like a stick of furniture to me they
have almost no empathy at all no
sympathy for anyone no well that about a
pathological liar someone who can't
control his ability to tell the truth
he's impulsively just lying he enjoys
lying it's a thrill out of lying out of
fooling you my lies are simply designed
to acquire money and move on I'm
actually matter of fact a lot of the
articles if you read the Atlantic won a
couple of the different people that they
talked to in my case they said the thing
is in cox's in Matt's personal life he's
extremely honest person
it's only when it comes to running a
scam so if I'm running a scam of course
I'm going to tell you what
to tell you to acquire what I what I
want but in my social life I'm not I'm
not gonna lie to you there's nothing
no I'll just tell you the truth this is
what's going on you'll deal with there
you won't
so sociopaths to you is its there's no
emotion
yeah you're a stick of furniture you're
not I don't I wouldn't say emotional is
I mean Atlas there's very varying
degrees of everything there are people
that are are schizophrenic and they
happen to have a little bit of paranoia
on one or two small subjects then there
are guys that are extremely delusional
they just see things that aren't that
they're hear things that they they
believe things that are just outrageous
you know so there's always varying
degrees the moment you came in you look
paranoid from the moment you stepped in
you were paranoid oh wait I cuz you keep
mind how this all occurred I literally
got a couple emails and I had seen the
program and I seen the same same in the
bowl and I'd seen the other one a part
of another one I watched the whole whole
thing which we talked about the guy with
the Michael Franzese yes yes yeah which
was great he was great and so it
happened very quickly and it was like
okay there was next thing I know I'm
walking in I mean I I think like I'm CIA
or do when you came a little bit because
I didn't I thought at some point we
would somebody would say hey you know
asked me some questions you know it that
like crazy yeah of course I thought
there would be some kind of a setup
instead I didn't I'm walking here I'm
still waiting like okay well at some
point they're gonna sit me down and say
okay well here's what we're here's what
we know here's what we're gonna film and
here's a instead I walk in and it's and
it's like sit down I know everything
about shop and then Hawk is over here to
your right yeah the intimidation thing
you know I mean it's a little shocking
Wow okay
you
[Music]